yeah all right we're back on a little
daily show that he's a Sunday Saturday
right yeah it's Mother's Day tomorrow I
know that that's okay I made
arrangements yeah I got my ass covered
[Laughter]
but yeah so before we get too much into
it I want to do like a couple of shout
outs that I just had yesterday I
actually shouted these out of the main
show to which we recorded
last night but since that isn't going up
till Tuesday or Monday if you're a
patron that I wanted to shout them out
sooner just so we got everything covered
so I definitely in the mail yesterday we
got a very very nice letter from sway
who also sent us a very generous cash
donation yes oh thank you very much for
that I actually read the letter on the
show so right that was on the main show
resent my dad's on the mange okay it's
gonna be animation yes oh it's gonna be
on the on the big main show because like
I said I like to shout people out like
on a daily basis but I know everybody
doesn't watch the daily ones you know
what I mean just like random viewers so
I do want to make sure like everybody
gets shouted out like yeah we're getting
into it we're getting more patrons we're
getting people centered just sending us
money yeah you know like money you guys
haven't seen it yeah Chris you got to
see idiocracy I said it's hard to find I
couldn't get it you can't get it all
blue right you can only get it on DVD
there won't be a blu-ray release maybe
because it's not um cuz isn't blu-ray I
didn't actually know this but isn't
blu-ray one particular company only like
isn't it Sony or I don't know you can't
get your lives on blu-ray either because
there's some yeah because there's some
if movie companies that don't like you
know I mean cuz they try to do like HD
disc and blu-ray and it's like yeah that
is anything you do why they don't do it
for True Lies they came out and said
they won't do true lies because they
thought it had a stereotypical portrayal
of [ __ ] Islamic terrorists so they
won't put any better put it out although
they released other movies that have
that so it's just it's it's because the
fam it's the particular guys that was
Cameron was it James Cameron
I don't think it was yeah it's just I
haven't seen it the particular directed
it moves behind it either he doesn't
want it out there you know and I think
that I don't know if any companies want
to touch well you can you just can't you
can get office spaces
off the space on blu-ray but for some
reason you can't get you can't get giddy
aqua see yeah I don't know I don't know
what company put idiocracy out actually
yeah they don't like you making fun of
dumb people yes yeah they want and they
didn't like I don't think they liked the
idea [ __ ] de-evolution and like
backwards eugenics you know how people
can breed themselves to be dumber I
didn't know they didn't like that
evidently yeah I don't know sometimes it
just might be the company that owns it I
don't necessarily want there to be like
a conspiracy behind it no there's always
conspiracy there's always a meeting yes
so like I said so so I was trying to do
another shout out before you went off on
one of your tirades it's not a sad way
is it tangent I'm trying to like get
okay you say tomato i said no i wanted
to do another shout out that i got a
PayPal donation yesterday from a fan
named basil and his wife Jocelyn and
they wanted to give a shout out to
Jocelyn's mom or as old mother-in-law
named Nancy Swan who was just recovering
from surgery and she listens to the show
like they all listen to the show
together and she's a big fan and they
thought that she would get a big kick
out of getting you know shout it out on
the show so get well Nancy Swan we like
I said we also shouted you out on the
main show but that doesn't come out for
a few days so I wanted to make sure like
I didn't like there wasn't too much lag
between the two things tape Miss Swan
takes on that pain medication the pain
medication reporter takes my payment
well you know I don't know what is she
recovering from cancer cancer yeah all
right so what else what else do we have
on the agenda today yeah what else do we
have on the agenda say I just did you
just say cancer and I was thinking my
mom recovered from cancer she did into
my
my mom lost a kidney her entire kidney
was the size of a dam the doctor said it
was you know he picked up one of those
uh handy white bottles you know they're
like that big around yeah he says you
kidneys that size that's all cancer it's
just a big [ __ ] rocket cancer yeah
that was a long time ago they cut that
out yeah that was like ten years ago
something like that I was waiting in the
damn operating room for her to come out
and talk to us like he was like that
when the dog will you see a doctor do
this
you're like oh [ __ ] and he's like yeah
he's like yeah I got it out of there III
don't think you know I think she's gonna
be all right we just have to see I mean
all's it takes is just one little cell
to fall back in there well because the
kind she had you couldn't use chemo on
it
you had one little cell can get in there
and it could start back up and we're
just gonna we're just going to see now
it's just like
all right thanks doctor there's been a
long time now just one couple of months
a couple months back she said that I had
my last cancer checkup it's not coming
back it would have come back by now yeah
you think cuz like I said that was at
least ten years ago
cuz that was before you and me I mean we
knew each other then but that was before
you and me started yeah yeah so that's
yeah that's got to be like 10 years ago
yeah maybe a little bit more cuz I
remember I was still working in Daytona
at the time because I was tell me
based on what the doctor you know when
you see a doctor come out of the womb
you know that's that's really something
you don't ever wanna know you just a
doctor making that gesture yeah when he
comes into your room it's like not good
for morale yeah he didn't he wasn't he
didn't inspire me too much man
so I was like okay he bought her sneeze
ten way I interpreted it is that he's
telling me that he bought her some time
but she's gonna die right that's how
it's not how that's not how it worked
out that she didn't die I have to say
though that it's like that just you
doing that doctor gesture reminded me of
life what the hell I can't remember what
commercial it was for US firm for one of
those wireless companies like you know
just okay is not okay or whatever that I
don't remember what company that is but
they used to show this commercial and we
used to see it like in the theater like
before so the movies sometimes and it's
like the doctor would come in and he'd
be like hey I got reinstated or whatever
it's like
like walks into this person's room and
they're like uh do you know what you're
doing he's like yeah kind of we'll
figure it out together yeah it's like
for some reason that always really made
me laugh even though it's like really
[ __ ] horrifying to think about but I
don't know I have a dark sense of humor
I guess but that always kind of made me
laugh that commercial if you know what
I'm talking about
but yeah so do you have anything else
you want to say I know this is like no
cuz we recorded the show we recorded the
show last night yeah another long one I
think it ended up being two hours and 48
minutes or something that's a pretty
good show I was kind of trashed that
last one quarter of it right I think
you're still coherent yeah I was just
holding on
I mean holding on to the cherry so many
legs yeah you started yelling a little
bit but not like not in like not in like
a ranting like you know crazy uncle at
Thanksgiving type away but kind of like
just I don't like just so you didn't
realize how loud your voice was a boy
just kind of liked that you were still
like coherent though if I only had one
eyes and it was strong but I I you know
over the carotid the three hours we were
yeah I drank it over the course of three
hours though part of the beauty of the
show is like I'm watching Tom trying to
hold on
that might be why like there's a large
percentage of people they're tuning in
just to see if you start jumping around
like it like a monkey or something like
it by jumping up and down in the chair
yeah I've seen some comments in the past
man Tom he talks she talks too much
let's just hear the case little [ __ ] if
we just hear the case you can just
[ __ ] read that [ __ ] off Wikipedia
there's gotta be some kind of [ __ ]
interaction with the [ __ ] case yeah I
mean I don't like I said I do like to
talk about the case and sometimes I get
annoyed if we get like too far off yeah
I'm like wow it really because sometimes
I'm kind of getting tired and I'm just
like I really want to finish this I can
go to bay it but um you know it means
sometimes I'm starting to wind up
towards the end yeah axe is kind of like
a [ __ ] stimulant to me you know I
mean my mind starts going down these
crazy paths so I started asking
questions
you went yeah you went way off on a
tangent about UFOs last night yeah well
because we were talking oh yeah yeah
yeah I remember we were talking about
polygraph test
yeah then for some reason you
went off on the Travis Walton thing yeah
it seemed like a long time like when I
was only a few say now it wasn't a few
seconds it was 10 or 15 minutes I think
I was just trying to point out that ok
he was he was demonstrating the the
reason why you should or shouldn't take
polygraph tests no it's not what I was
saying that's not what I meant I don't
know what I said but I just what I meant
what I meant was
sometimes that polygraph [ __ ] my mind
up yeah because I but you know I know
there are extraterrestrials yeah I
suspect that they're coming here because
military pilots are footing to see and
they're showing the videos now the
things that they're seeing and I don't
have never seen anything any kind of
repulsion like that it's not an error
you're gonna know the man something's
coming here I don't think that we're
making that concept although there's a
show I got an idea for a show oh yeah
yeah I get to in a sec let me take over
that means to get to me and we get to
microphone okay the what I was trying to
say was is that even though I believe in
extraterrestrials I you know there's got
to be things on other planets so there
wouldn't be a universe you know I mean
we live in the biblical universe with
the [ __ ] earth in the center and just
in a ball you know what I mean yeah
because it's not [ __ ] paddles on
pedestals and [ __ ] I just can't believe
that Travis Walton story yeah
but they passed polygraphs tests and
that makes me think that you can beat
polygraph tests or people can [ __ ] up
giving you a polygraph test to where
you'll pass it when you shouldn't have
or anyone except that no I said because
there's another idea when I was saying I
didn't know what's that felt is all
about feelings you hurt my feelings
no I said what I was saying was that
there is another possibility in that the
person actually does think that they're
telling the truth because
they misinterpreted what they saw or
they dreamed it and forgot that they
dreamed it it didn't really happen yes
too many dudes are involved with the
thing that's another I'm just saying
that's another possibility I'm not
saying that happened in their case I'm
just saying that's another possibility
but like the person might actually
genuinely believe that they're telling
the truth and said they might pass a
polygraph test because they think
they're because they're not sort of sad
about it the only way I think they could
have passed that polygraph test is if
that is if they did see a [ __ ] UFO
and Travis Walton was injured in it and
was returned later well and he just
believed what he just believed he saw
what he claims to have seen because
she's the guy that thought that he got
caught he got taken up on the thing and
there was like well no never working on
my stuff I don't buy that I don't buy
that part I just don't buy that part of
it in the description of inside the ship
maybe he was in there but I don't think
he ever regained consciousness David if
they had the technology to bring up dude
back to life they'd have the technology
to keep a dude under yeah or make him
like forget what make him forget
anything
you think maybe he just invented that
memory yeah because that can't happen
I mean memories can't get it planted
like I said that's why maybe some people
that can pass polygraph tests and they
have these like crazy stories maybe it
doesn't necessarily mean that they're
lying it just means that they've become
so convinced that that memory really
happened that they genuinely think that
they're telling the truth would you they
can pass a polygraph yeah that's all I'm
saying I think maybe if if that whole
case was true in other words you know I
mean which I think it is I think it is a
true case like you know the cops are
involved in the game of polygraph test
and that they all were there and that
they passed the polygraph which that it
seems to be true that it seems to mean
that has that has you know some
witnesses who said they were there the
cops said that they that they saw him
out there you know what I mean and that
they took the polygraph so it must have
happened but I think what happened was
is they were out there and he out there
[ __ ] around at night doing their job
coming back from logging and they saw a
UFO
Travis ran out there and got it he got
killed by it somehow they said it looked
like a lightning bolt or something
down out of it I got an arc and blew him
up into the air like a grenade went off
yeah and then they ran and they went
back he was gone then he got returned
later so I guess it killed him and they
somehow fixed him and then returned him
must have killed him by axe okay but
this whole thing about biological
entities and then him [ __ ] man and up
and trying to fight them and you know I
stylist it's just sound it sounds very
unlike I said Shane might yeah he very
well might have been injured in or
whatever weird should happened and then
he just like imagine that yeah cuz her
dreamed it and then he thought it really
had that's what really happened right
because I believe it'd be a lot more
likely that he that his body was taken
inside and that he was repaired using
some technology and then the people that
did it were actually living machines I
don't believe they were biological yeah
I mean I think was a droid big droid
ship so kind of probe ship living a
living droid ship this is this
biological entity [ __ ] traveling through
space it's unlikely the more I know
about it you know the more I think it's
unlikely yeah I just because I don't
think biological I think biological
life-forms are only a stepping stone
towards de living machines yeah that's
what I mean in terms of evolution just
like out of that damn Steven Spielberg
movie ai yeah you know the the AI
creatures saw mankind is kind of like
their prototype they you know I mean cuz
that owed their creation to him but they
were their own beings you know and they
were machine based that was a Steven
Spielberg and Stanley Kubrick wasn't it
I think so
it was a weird combo if ever there was I
remember it being a pretty good movie
but every other theater um I liked it
has a little [ __ ] so yeah it had some
weird [ __ ] in there you know which
should not be surprising considering the
two people hit the Senate the story
centered around a little kid for some
mysterious there were a robot that looks
like a little kid yeah and I just don't
really think that was really the way to
go with the story I guess they were
trying to humanize yeah the robots a lot
yeah but it was a movie from another era
where you had to humanize them more you
know I mean
have been better to have the story you
know centered around something else I'd
have to see it again like I said I
remember seeing it in the theater and
liking it but thinking some parts of it
were a little like weird like it didn't
know well like what tone it wanted to
send one like I said which is not
surprising considering I mean Steven
spiel were in Stanley Kubrick are two
very different directors and it's funny
because when I saw it I was like yeah
that's exactly what like when I heard
those two guys were making a movie
together I'm like yeah that's exactly
what happen like all this what I liked
it but it was just like a strange
experience but I'd have to see it again
because it's been many the Pentagon the
Pentagon is coming out they have videos
of what these pilots have been seeing
recently and the Pentagon said it's
quite frequent that's a stunning
statement aliens everywhere
they said this quite frequent man that's
a damn you know what they're showing is
not something that you it's not
something you would consider that had
biological creatures in it like one of
them was just a damn cube with a sphere
and it was clear you know I mean that
doesn't sound like a spaceship well like
he said it smelled just drones why the
hell would they bother like coming here
or maybe or if they come here that's
then yeah that is them that machine you
know and the other thing is it's
something flying across the surface of
the water they get a lock on it and it's
moving at Mach speed like that it was
moving I think it might have been mocked
two-point-five I think they said which
is the speed of a air-to-air missile but
it doesn't have any exhaust plume coming
out of the back of it and and you know I
mean like a rocket
yeah and it's small this is very small
like the size of US missile so how many
creatures are you gonna be able to stuff
in that thing and it was cooking oh yeah
it was book unless the aliens are like
little bitty like a little Smurfs sighs
I think he's just unlikely I think it's
more likely that their machine based
intelligence yeah well it would make
sense like I said since we're kind of
heading in that direction
yeah you would think that said if there
was like an alien civilization that was
that far ahead of us they would have
gone that way like a long time right why
would they want biological body said age
and die yeah grow old you can roll aim
right you could download you
consciousness into a machine or into an
Internet and live forever in a heaven
like state and then take control of
probes if you went you know to do things
like travel through space you can once
the probe gets there you can transfer
your consciousness into the probe and be
the probe for a while yeah yeah you be
the probe which is like well we would
call it remote control but even better
than remote control you know I mean
you're the pro yeah you got your own
senses in your own and some of the [ __ ]
that that the that the French Jean
Thomas Young Temari saw you know in the
open series of sightings big triangles
that were sending down look like a laser
beam with a ball that would go down into
the water and come back up like it was
measuring something and they would just
move along and did what why would a
that's just not something a biological
entity would I think be doing yeah it
was like robotic type behavior no
telling what it was doing just you know
I mean you can't grasp it but the whole
police station saw it you know and they
were going all over the city measuring
the dams church steeples and [ __ ] but
the damn ball yeah weird take off and
move just totally ignoring everybody
well like I said it would be like us
like hovering over a it he'll probably
it's like they probably see evidently
not no interest in any any in people
more interested in the water and more
interested in damned church steeple it's
just weird
it just sounds like something robot
would do or a living machine sure that
his priorities revert would be very
different than say like you know some
happy-go-lucky gray alien with big ol
eyes you know that man 1 to 6 something
up your butthole [ __ ] show that did
we do a show about Travis Walton we did
didn't we I feel like we probably I good
maybe we did I remember what my idea the
show was some of these crafts that they
got recorded that the Air Force has on
these cameras kind of reminds me a
phenomenon that I I just heard about but
I can't even find videos of it they had
a guy who was taking a damn
limpet bar wait you know how like I have
and they have the the weights on the end
of them yeah well he had one of those
Olympic bars but it only had the dam
rotating weight on one side of it then
he takes like a 90 pound weight and puts
it on the end of that and then uses an
electric drill with a special like
rubber wheel that he had attached to it
spin that way up to a real high rpm it
looks like it was going maybe like 100
miles an hour all right and then once
that once that weight was spin and he
picked that bar up like it was nothing
just with one hand he's a little old man
that these rotating weights
somehow because the inertia in there or
the gyroscopic forces allow you to move
a heavy object with very little energy
yeah I remember looking like that I
would like to make a show about this
effect and who who figured this up who
figured this out is it useful what can
you do with it because I've read some
[ __ ] this is back when I was a kid that
they were using ideas like that they
were trying to they were trying to use
it in aircraft to be kind of like mass
reduction yeah to make a craft less
massive or at least appear to be less
massive as its flying because it's got
rotating weights in it right I want to
know about the plausibility of that and
then evidently it is claimed that
there's kind of an that there's kind of
an effort to actively suppress that idea
of doing that which might indicate some
kind of a secret aircraft program
perhaps so like let's say you got a
flying saucer right uh-huh
it's round could you spin a big weight
around it and make that flying saucer do
something gyroscopic like stand upright
and then with small jets could you get
that thing to fly around what if you had
one disc that was weighed a lot massive
you know what I mean cast-iron inside of
there
spinning fast maybe with a jet engine
spinning it and then below it another
one spin in the opposite direction what
happens then yeah
does it balance each other out does it
become weightless or seem to become
weightless I don't know what you want
well we'll have to wait a couple weeks
is you that already got like you think
I'd be the show uh well maybe I'd have
to look into it I don't really like know
much about it honestly I remember you
should telling me something about it
like years ago but I don't know I saw a
film and it looked like it was taken
from the 70s of an old man doing that
with that wait yeah I want to spin he
was just moving it all around like it
was nothing yeah you showed me that and
he didn't I showed it to you tonight
yeah and he didn't worry that dude
didn't weigh anything that was years ago
yeah and I was like look at that [ __ ]
yeah you never hear about that it's some
kind of gyroscopic force and and you
would think someone would try to use
that if they could yeah I mean you know
like I said I'd have to look into it cuz
I don't really know you know I just
remember you showing me something like
that it was a long time ago yeah well
how does the effect work in space like
would it work in space or is it had to
be in a gravitational field you have to
be touching the ground
what happens if the guy jumps up in the
air yeah what's happened yeah you know I
mean do you need to be standing on the
ground to get leverage to get the spin
to work makes me want to get in there
try saucers in my own garage
you tell you we're talking about that
like a few years ago that you're gonna
build a flying saucer yeah that's like
that was a couple years ago yeah I was
gonna I was gonna build a flying saucer
out of the [ __ ] out of the little
electric motors somebody else beat you
to it though yeah a little drone yeah a
little drone thanks you know what I mean
yeah the guy guys to do good I mean now
they have to run thousands of little
propellers yeah you know it's all
Wireless he's doing it with his damn
tablet cuz we were gonna do that and see
if we could get like people to report a
UFO like in the neighborhood oh that one
because I also talked about riding it
yeah
oh yeah there's a guy Jeremy doing it he
beat me to it
the other one was is to buy it to buy a
drum and decorate it like a UFO and put
a bunch of LEDs on it fly it around the
neighborhood and wait and see if he made
reports it as a UFO yeah yeah well it
was like we were gonna do that or we
were gonna dress you up as skunk ape yep
you found in the woods it was you
ologists yeah though it wasn't it wasn't
it wasn't gonna be a hoax it was gonna
be a joke it was gonna be a it was gonna
be obvious I tell people I wanted to
test we see what gave us that idea is
because in the newspaper somebody on the
on a damn commercial train went through
the dam there's a train track around
here somewhere and reported a humanoid
Harry a Bigfoot and that was in a
newspaper yeah it was a bear though I
guarantee you as a bear well there's
bears all over bears all over place yeah
there's all kind of creatures all over
the place it wasn't even in it it wasn't
even in the woods it's like in the
suburbs
well hey Bigfoot wants to like come down
and he's looking at some properties yeah
he doesn't want to live out in the
middle of nowhere anymore
right he's looking to like buy a nice
little suburban home for him this little
big feat family I don't know
all right you ready to wrap it up for
Saturday all right so you guys have the
rest of the rest of your Saturday hope
it's a good one and stay safe out there
we will talk to you again tomorrow